Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That
number is 2192. David P. Many of you wrote in
and called in and said, David, you got to
sue them over that documentary where they
make you seem like a conspiracy theorist if you
don't know what I'm talking about. Yesterday I
talked about my inclusion in a documentary about
Malaysian Malaysian Airlines Flight 370 wherein a
clip of me is used that makes me look like a
conspiracy theorist, even though in the clip
I'm debunking that conspiracy theory. Here's
one caller who says, Sue the hell out of them.
Speaker 3: Hey, David, I just listened
to your piece on the Malaysian flight
conspiracy theory. Yeah. That you were on on
Netflix. Just a quick comment. You absolutely
should sue. You should sue. Those people took your
comments completely out of context. And although
you're not inclined to do so, remember that, you
know, this is how some of these places and people
operate. And so there needs to be consequences.
And you, I'm sure, have the resources to do
it. So, yeah, 100% sue and make them pay.
Speaker 1: All right. Well, there is one
demand that I sue. I'm just not very litigious
by nature, you know, And it's partially my fault
what happened, as I explained. But it would be
great content for me to sue. So that would be the
one draw to it. We'll explore. All right. We've
got a great bonus show for you today. Electric
vehicle stores, I guess, is what we're calling
them, are going to be restricted in the state
of Mississippi. Oklahoma Republicans have voted to
let teachers hit kids with disabilities in school.
Yeah, and South Carolina who get abortions. South
Carolina women who get abortions could face the
death penalty under a proposed new bill. Yeah,
it's insane what's happening. All of those stories
and more on today's bonus show. Sign up and
join Pacman dot com. You'll get instant access.